pierce brosnan and his 19 year old son  dillan looking dapper over the holiday  weekend the father-son duo were snapped  outside Malibu Soho House Sunday night  looking dashing in casual Blazers Dylan  clearly inherited his father's good  looks  check out his modeling shots in the  spring/summer 2016 campaign for Burberry  where he goes shirtless in one of the  designers signature trench coats  complete with shaggy hair and freckles  the Burberry job isn't Dylan's first  modeling gig he showed off a more formal  side for a YSL campaign in November 2014  looking handsome in a black suit and  bowtie and Dylan is not the only  handsome Brosnan offspring his brothers  Sean and Paris or head-turners when they  accompanied their famous dad to the no  escape premiere last August